Salut à tous, c'est Pêcheur de Trésors, aujourd'hui on est en compagnie d'Alex, c'est de sa petite famille
Et on va pêcher sous un pont, c'est un pont pieton, il n'y aura peut-être pas grand chose, mais des fois il y a quand même des petites surprises intéressantes
Je crois que j'ai quelque chose
Première trouvaille
Qui a du poids
Une poussette
Il n'y a pas le bébé avec ?
Ah bah elle est neuve
Ah non, il n'y ait pas, dommage
Franchement c'est ouf en bon état comme ça
Mais ça vaut au moins 50€ non ?
Ouais c'est de la merde
Allez vas-y, qu'est-ce que tu nous trouve de beau ?
Bah je vais te le dire
Ah il y a du poids on dirait
Waouh la barre de fer
Celle là, ça fait un moment qu'elle est dans l'eau
Bravo
Ah c'est un tube
Alex qui vient de nous faire une montre
Festina
En plus tu vois, elle s'est cassée donc elle est tombée du poignet
Elle n'est pas si vieille que ça
Elle n'a pas pris l'eau à l'intérieur
Non
Elle marche, elle tourne, regarde
Elle est à l'heure
Elle tourne
Elle tourne, elle est à l'heure
Je te jure
Regarde
C'est la température ça
Ouais, elle marche
Bon dans l'eau il fait
16 degrés je sais pas
L'humidité est à 100%
Elle marche, elle tourne
Il y a l'humidité
Peut-être qu'il y en a qui connaîtront mieux que nous
Festina
Ça va
Franchement je pense que tu peux y aller faire changer le bracelet
Comment ça doit coûter
Je vais aller voir ça
Ça va pas être cher
Modèle collection F200345
Water résistante
Là pour le coup je la confirme qu'elle est résistante à l'eau
J'ai pas mon maillot moi
On peut se baigner tout nu ici
C'est vrai ?
C'est pas bon pour YouTube on va se faire strike
On floute
A poil !
On n'a pas besoin de flouter grand chose
Ah voilà, je suis dessus
Tu veux y aller ?
Non je ne veux pas y aller
Bon du coup
Il faudrait que quelqu'un tienne la corde pour me montrer
Il y a un objet avec une drôle de forme
Il a l'air plutôt gros mais il n'accroche pas bien
Donc on va voir
En plus elle est bonne l'eau
Ouais super
Allez, bon  courage
Il y a de la vase par contre
C'est mieux que l'hiver
Ça va mieux ?
Ouais
C'est profond là non ?
Je te la détends
Alors est-ce que j'ai pied déjà ?
Non pas super non
T'es sérieux ?
Ouais
Il y a un truc qui m'a mordu
Sérieux ?
Il m'a attrapé la peau
J'ai filmé son cri viril
Ah bah non mais ta gueule, ça fait peur
Tu as perdu toute crédibilité
Au revoir
Il va se faire manger par une bête féroce
Vas-y, tires
Vas-y
J'ai un truc dans la main là
Ah ouais ?
Aidez le
C'est dans la vase
Ouais c'est bon je le sens
Ouais c'est gros
Mais j'ai dans la main là
J'aurais dû garder les chaussures c'est horrible au fond
Tu veux tes pompes ?
On va essayer de le remettre
Ah il y a du...
C'est quoi ça ?
Du câble
Il y a du lestage
Oh il y a du lest
Du plastique que j'ai
Du plastique ?
Vas-y
Tiens
Je vais l'attacher
Allez là on est bon
C'est vaseux
C'est bon là tu penses ?
Ouais
C'est accroché
J'ai fait un noeud
Alors petit naturiste tu penses qu'on a quoi ?
Pour l'instant on va utiliser le treuil parce que c'est trop lourd
Et c'est enfoncé. Franchement c'est bizarre, j'ai jamais vu un truc comme ça
Un pronostic ?
Nan
Franchement aucune idée
Moi je pense que c'est une petite barque
Petite barque
On n'a pas tendu avant
Ouais mais ça treuille
C'est vraiment étrange hein
C'est vrai que c'est bizarre hein
Ca a un air de chambre à air
Mais il y a des trucs à l'intérieur donc ...
Ouais ils ont vidé le cuivre
Ouais c'est clairement du câble de cuivre volé
On peut le tirer je pense
J'ai enlevé le béton
On va enlever le béton
Oh il doit y avoir une sacrée quantité
Ouais il doit être gros
Et c'est du sacré câble ça
Là il y a une bonne dépollution là parce qu'avec tout ce plastique
Regarde c'est ça tu avais, des gros là
Allez
Putain il vient
On essaie un peu l'autre côté pour voir
Je pense qu'il se va s'accrocher
Ah non
Non non
Vas-y
Il y en a des kilos
Ça y est on a
C'est fini
C'est pas du câble SNCF ça ?
Il est balèze
C'est bon le câble il vient
Ouais ça y est
Ça y est enfin
On va rejeter l'aimant parce qu'il y avait des trucs qui accrochaient
Attendez les gars c'est pas fini
Ah c'est pas fini
C'est pas fini
Je me suis peu sali
Ah
Il y a une odeur en plus c'est génial
Ça recommence
T'as raison il doit être super long
On va l'accrocher à la voiture et on sort du parking
Et trainant tout le bordel
Bon allez je vais tenter de traverser le pont
Par dessous
C'est la seule solution ?
Ouais
En fait ça ne sert à rien pour la vidéo
Mais bon
En vrai ça fait peur
Au pire tu tombes
Non mais le problème c'est aussi les mains
Le problème c'est que si tu tombe il n'y a pas d'eau et il y a des rochers
C'est ça
C'est vrai qu'il y a les bouts du pont
Bon les gars préparez a appeler le 17 ou le 15
Tu vas tomber avec les gants comme ça
Ouais ça glisse
Ça glisse beaucoup
C'est mal parti
Il va tomber là
Mais c'est à barres au mieux là !
Pourquoi tu vas passes pas par dessus ?
Trop chiant
Mais pourquoi tu n'es pas passé sur le pont ?
Ah ouais, pas bête
Bisous dans l'oreille
Gentil petit
Et la petite fourchette
Ah ah ah
Ne mangez pas les fourchettes
On vous rappelle que c'est l'aliment qu'il faut mordre
Ah ce qu'il en reste de la trottinette
Ah c'était bien ça alors
Celle là aussi on la restaure ?
Ouais restaure là Alex
J'ai déjà fait une comme ça
Autant abimée ?
Pire que ça !
Ouais c'est de l'eau de mer en plus
Bon bah sympa
Le câble il n'arrête pas de sortir, on est obligé de treuiller
C'est une grosse galère
Donc pour aujourd'hui on va arrêter
Et en plus il fait super chaud
Je vais découper le morceau qu'on a déjà sorti
Et on reviendra à récupérer le reste dans une autre vidéo
Si vous voulez dites-le moi en commentaire
Et on se dit à la semaine prochaine
Pour une nouvelle vidéo de Pêche à l'aimant
Ça gère
Ouais ça marche
Elle est solide
Par contre il est en train de plier
Il a activé le freinage d'urgence
Ouais c'était très limite le poids
C'était une bonne expérience ?
Ouais franchement j'ai adoré
Ah tu veux aussi ?
Non c'est bon